(violins playing)
- [Tiffany] My mom is
significantly older than me,
and she always says, she's like,
"This is just one of those
things that in my lifetime,
"I just never thought I'd see."
The City of South Fulton Municipal Court
is the only court system
in the entire country
that's run entirely by
African American women.
(orchestral music)
- The City of South Fulton
is Georgia's newest city.
It was started in 2017.
We became a city with a large
African American population.
One of the largest in the country.
It is a city that is
made up of urban, rural,
and suburban communities,
and I truly think
this is one of the best
little places in America.
- The mayor appointed me first.
And then I know you need a
solicitor and a public defender.
Then, I had to go about
selecting a court administrator.
She, along with myself,
hired the rest of the staff.
So that's kind of how it came about.
- I had the first realization
of the specialness
of our court and the first response that
I have was like, oh, black girl magic.
(violins playing)
- [Guard] All right, and if
you all have any cell phones,
please put cell phone on off.
- Oftentimes, particularly
for African Americans,
people feel railroaded by the system.
A municipal court is often
people's first interaction
with the judicial system.
So it's my position that
we have to get it right,
because we can change the
perception of the system
if they have a personal
experience that's counter to that.
Counter to what they perceived
and what they've heard.
And so you know, in South Fulton,
we're not gonna be light on crime.
But we're gonna make sure that
your rights are protected.
I'm sorry, hold on.
Now you want me to hear you,
so you gotta raise your voice
up so that I can hear you.
We believe in being a model for what
a municipal court in a
progressive city looks like.
- All rise, the City of
South Fulton Municipal Court
is now in session.
Honorable Tiffany Carter
Sellers is the judge presiding.
- One of the things I
think makes our court
particularly unique is
how we treat people.
We try to take our time to educate people.
So when they pre-try a case with me
or they're present before the judge,
they really get information
about why they are pleading guilty.
We're not just saying
go do community service.
We're saying do community
service within our community.
Pre-trial was your opportunity to speak
with me about your case
and come to a resolution.
- The law does not require that the person
is appointed a public defender
for their first appearance here.
I mean in 2018 in a civilized society,
we just can do it better.
And so the city council
has been very gracious
in providing the funding necessary
to be able to have our public defenders
available whenever someone is arrested
for their first appearance here.
Particularly in municipal
courts it's uncommon,
and so the dynamic is
absolutely different.
This was my opportunity to
operate as a model court.
To think that we are
kind of the first court
run completely by African American women
is really heartwarming.
It's a lot of, I can't
believe it's taken 'til 2018.
Because I think for centuries
African American women
have just done some outstanding things.
I'm glad that we're leading the way
in showing people the
excellence that can occur.
I'm an eternal optimist, particularly
when it comes to the
criminal justice system.
(chiming)